قال المستشار الالماني اولى تشارلز انه
سيكون من الخطا الفادح التوقف تماما عن
الحديث مع الرئيس الروسي الذي من بوتينر
رغم من كل الاختلافات معه اضفها شورتز
خلال تسليمه في في تسليمه في هامرج جائزه
ماريونا دينهوف لايرينا شيرما كوفا من
منظمه الريال الحقوقيه الروسيه الحائزه
على جائزه نوبل للسلام عرف انه من المهم
ايضا اي واصله مع الرئيس الفرنسي كان
ممثلين عن دور مجموعه السبع للحوار مره
اخرى
الذي تحدث مع بوتن في الثاني من استمرار
انه تحدث عن الهاجمات الروسيه على البنيه
التحتيه للطاقه في اوكرانيا واكد ان اساس
السلام الذي لا تبنيه روسيا هو الانسحاب
القوات الروسيه مضيفه ان الحرب لن تنتهي
بانتصار روسيا ونزعتها التوسعيه حسب
تعبيره